well i don't know is a self-transforming
elf machine a deva
this is a phrase that has been
associated with me for many many years
i encounter self-transforming elf
machines
which are creatures
entities
perhaps although they're not made out of
matter they're made out of as nearly as
i can figure it out they're made out of
syntax driving light
but
if what your question
addresses is the issue of entities on
the other side
there are definitely
entities on the other side
for me
and there seem to be such for
many many other people
i'm not in any
by any standard sensitive
so if i get
entities
then they are substantial and capable of
defending themselves
it's one of the most
challenging parts of the whole
psychedelic landscape
because most people can accept the idea
of
disordered sensory
input recovery of traumatic memory
material so forth and so on but what are
we to do with an elf you know that
becomes a little harder to contextualize
in psychoanalytic theory although jung
did a good job when he said autonomous
elements can escape from the psyches
control and present themselves as
independent entities
i'm not sure he's ever seen
a self-transforming elf machine
oh it's it's the
defining characteristic of the true dmt
flash i mean it is not subtle
it's these things mob you like badly
trained rottweilers
they come bounding forward by the dozens
by the hundreds they jump into your body
they jump out of your body
they
and
i thought you know i mean it maps to
some degree over the archetype of the
little people the leprechaun the fae and
being irish and being jungian
i'm willing to entertain you know maybe
i have a special
uh
relationship to this stuff but then in
the amazon the people using dmt that i
studied in the early 70s the reason they
did it they said was to to speak with
the little people
uh what puzzles me about my contacts
with these beings is
it conforms to let's say the irish
model
they are
small
they live under hills or when you're
with them you have a sense that you are
somehow underground
they are full of
merriment
almost to a manic and frightening level
it's sort of like a bugs bunny cartoon
gone berserk
they are friendly
but play rough
in other words it's a land of explosions
and falling anvils it's like a road
runner cartoon or something but the
overwhelming feeling is
love
but i spell it luv to distinguish it
from the ordinary kind because it's just
this kind of crazy
childish
affection
and they're delighted
to have
me in their presence
well now that all sort of corresponds
with the irish model or with worldwide
folklore of little creatures little
people in the woods
what's happening that is not
mappable onto fairyland or leprechauns
or fintornian beings or anything like
that or anything else i've ever heard of
is that these entities have an agenda
and it's a very curious agenda
they
use a language which you see
you don't you it is made out of sound in
other words it's
it it is sound
but you see it
in that state and the entire point of
the encounter
from their perspective seems to be
to teach you to do this
they want you
to transform your language they want you
to speak
elfish
and you know what
if you've never done dmt and you just
smoked it and you're 30 seconds into
this experience and it's and this is
what it's come down to
you wonder
what to make of it i've thought about
this for
years and years and years and i don't
know why there should be an invisible
syntactical intelligence giving language
lessons in hyperspace
but
that that certainly consistently seems
to be what is happening and it seems to
me that language is some kind of
enterprise of human beings that is not
finished
that we have we have now left the grunts
and the digs of the elbow somewhat in
the dust
but the most articulate brilliantly
pronounced and projected english or
french or german or chinese is still
a poor
carrier of our intent a very limited
bandwidth for the intense
compression of data that we are trying
to put across to each other a language
that you can see is
far less ambiguous
than a language that you hear
if i read the paragraph of proust then
we could spend the rest of the afternoon
discussing what did he mean
but if we look at a piece of sculpture
by henry moore
we can discuss what did he mean but at a
certain level there is a kind of shared
bedrock
that isn't in the produced passage we
each stop at a different level with the
textual passage with the
three-dimensional object we all sort of
start from the same place and then work
out our interpretations you know is it a
nude is it an animal uh is it bronze is
it wood
is it
poignant is it comical so forth and so
on so
uh
this is
uh
you know not a very scientific part of
the rap because it's very hard to
convince people that there are non-human
intelligences this side of ganepogan
newbie and when you tell them that these
non-human intelligences are ex
accessed through the diminutive
mushrooms growing on their front lawn
they just write you off as a squirrel
but this question of the non-human
intelligences is very very much on the
agenda all shamans in all times and
places
have
have claimed this once you've
encountered these things
you have to take them seriously
to the point of you have to understand
where do they fit into the great order
of being
what are
these things how can there be a life
form not made of matter in other words
how can they be intelligent and coherent
but have no fixed body outline where are
they when you're not there
is it an ongoing thing
are they
is something going on on this planet are
these the controllers are you getting
into a back channel that you're not
weren't cleared for
or
and this is to my mind the most chilling
and appalling and exhilarating
possibility of all
when you go back over the shamanism
thing
you say you know you shamans now where
is this all coming from
they will tell you it comes from
ancestors
well that's a cheerful and fairly
sanitized concept but when you
deconstruct it ancestors are dead people
what is actually being suggested there
is that there is a kind of ecology of
souls one energy threshold over
that is co-present with this world
well strangely enough that's what the
irish myth of the fae
says
says these are dead people
these are souls that linger in our
environment and this is what souls look
like
again folklore is only a guide but if
what we are dabbling with if what lies
at the end of the road of shamanism is
the dissolution of the boundary between
life and death itself
then the million-year intuition that
this was a path worth following will be
dramatically
vindicated
and one of the reasons i've preached dmt
so
furiously is i just want a larger body
of people to take it so that we can
compare data
we need to understand you know how is
this possible it raises a whole host of
questions
one is
not only how is this possible but then
given that is this possible how has it
been kept secret
how can
millions of people
go to the grave raise children hold jobs
so forth and so on go to the grave and
the news of a doorway
standing that
a gate
hasn't penetrated i mean most people
believe they're imprisoned
in this world and that the only hope is
maybe 15 years at the ashram and hideous
acts of
self-abnegation and control and so forth
and so on and actually the boundary
between us and unspeakably bizarre world
it's
30 seconds away at any time as long as
you have dmt available to smoke
that's appalling to me i mean it means
we don't know nothing
yeah well the classical myth about
leprechauns is that they want to keep
you
if they catch you they or if you mess
with them they'll hold you and then you
have to bargain your way out and the
bargain is always the solution of a
riddle
notice that what's happening here is
it's all about linguistic prowess
it's all about poetic skill it's all
about language ability
only the eloquent
only the clever only those who are
masters of riddlery and pun
are acceptable to these entities
apparently that's what they value
why
i guess because they're made of language
so and and they themselves have
when i try to describe to people what
they are or what they look like various
things can be said they're like
self-dribbling jeweled basketballs
in other words they don't have faces or
anything not the little yellow
leather jerkins and the curve
pointed shoes not that dribbling self
self dribbling jeweled basketballs and
they use the language to
make objects
that's what this language how this
language is different from ordinary
english english we can make meaning
the dmt language makes objects it's like
a higher dimensional language and so
these things bound forward with the
complete purpose of delighting you
and they reach into the air into their
bodies in some into some nearby
invisible dimension and they pull out
what i would call words
puns
objects
hallucinations
things which manage to be all those
things simultaneously
and they say look at this and it's
purely designed to dazzle and astound
and then a colleague will
elbow the little guy aside and say no
look at this and they're all in front of
you chirping clamoring and these objects
that they make begin themselves to speak
and float away and reproduce
and you're you know you've arrived 30
seconds ago you were sitting in a room
with your grubby friend somewhere
pursuing spiritual understanding now
this
is going on and it's very hard to not be
horrified i mean the cognitive
dissonance the neck snapping switch of
dimensions and then after about three
four five minutes
it
retracts
it loses its
vitality and it begins to pull away from
you almost like a boat pulling away from
a dock and in fact i had one trip where
metaphorically not having hands
they all turned and waved and said
[Music]
which is of course absurd
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you